من خلق الهدنه
الطرف الاخر
تبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بات كتبادل اطلاق النار جزء من يوميات
الحرب الدائره رحاها في شوارع الخرطوم
هدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ما انطلقت حتى
بدات البيانات بالصدور تاره من الجيش الذي
قال انه رصد استمرار التحركات العسكريه
لقوات الدعم داخل وخارج العاصمه ومحاوله
السيطره على مواقع وتقييد تحركات
المواطنين بالاضافه الى حركه كثيفه
بمجموعات متفاوته نحو مصفاه الجيل للسيطره
عليها وخلق ازمه في امدادات الوقود بكامل
البلاد
قوات الدعم السريع من خلال حسابها على
تويتر شجبت انتهاك الجيش الهدنه متهمه
اياه بالقيام بالقصف العشوائي الامر الذي
يعرض حياه المدنيين للخطر هذا الشد والجذب
تزامن مع امال الجهات الدوليه في نجاح
الهدنه حيث حث مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل من خلال
حسابه في تويتر الطرفين على الالتزام حتى
يتم التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه المدنيين
اوعد الابرياء اما واشنطن حسب وزير
خارجيتها انتوني بلينكن فهي تعمل مع
شركائها لتشكيل لجنه تتفاوض على وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار في السودان
البرهان ودجلو حليفا الامس عدوا اليوم
اللذان تسبب على السلطه حتى الان في قتل
اكثر من
459 شخصا حسب الصحه العالميه التي قدرت ان
اعداد الضحايا اكثر من هذا الرقم بكثير اذ
لم يتم احصاء القتلى في مناطق كثيره بسبب
القصف الكثيف انس نماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات